I know it's not the question you asked
but we're gonna learn the same thing
from it and hopefully when we dive into
the actual question you'll see what's
going on okay how would you solve this
what would you do and the first natural
thing to do is to square both sides
right so you get this now once get all
over on one side does it factorize not
nicely okay so we'll watch here
tell me what to write 1 that's minus P
okay plus or minus 1 plus 4 double
negative okay so no wonder it didn't
factorize right see you have these guys
by the way do you recognize those
numbers no recognize hmm special number
anyway okay one of them is anyway now
have a look at this point you could
conclude cool I'm done right but there
is a problem isn't there what's the
problem okay now it's clouded by the
fact that there this number is
irrational right but the square root of
5 is like 2.2 2.3 2.4 or something like
that
my point is it's bigger than 1 okay in
other words one of these answers is
negative and one of them is positive
okay
so when you look at these answers you've
got a problem
okay because if for instance let's take
let's take X equals 1 minus root 5 1 2
okay if it's really a solution you
should be able to pop back into your
original line and it work right what
happens on your left hand side okay what
do you get you get the square root of 1
minus root 5 on 2 plus 1
yeah which is not
okay you got two over to there there's
the plus one okay so what's this going
to be this is the square root of three
minus root 5 on 2 okay now hold on a
second that's an actual number like
that's not that doesn't break the square
root or you what is that it's it's three
- okay
and so on ah but hold on hold on the
right-hand side the right-hand side we
just established is going to be negative
right it's gonna be this guy which
whatever it is is not this because this
is positive okay now you can think about
this another way of course because when
you're solving something like this right
you can think about it graphically what
would that look like what point of
intersection are we finding right well I
guess it would look like this let's see
y equals x we know what Y cos x looks
like looks like this what's why cuz the
square root of x plus one looks like
it's kind of like a sideways parabola
but it's only half of it and it's been
moved to the left left because you can
put in you get pretty negative one into
that and it works right so you getting
this and there's our solution there's
there's one plus root 5 on - okay
where's 1 minus root 5 on - well it
would be here but but we don't have that
part of the graph because the square
root of x plus 1 is not defined down
here because if you know functions and
investors and how we define them okay so
what's the point when you come down to
solutions no matter what they are so the
interesting about this thing is that it
doesn't break the square it it still
works but it's still not a solution ok
so you always must judge your solutions
whenever you end up down here according
to whether they satisfy your first line
or not ok
which brings us to the actual question
they asked which looks like this
let's see here okay so how did you
approach it what do we do what's the
first step change the power key yes so
we can say that's log of 2x plus K but
this is going to become log of x squared
right cool
now what where can we go from here
you got you've got what did you do
what'd you do
you cut the log off okay
that's it that's a crude and violent way
to do it but I kept mine so that the log
of that should be the same so the
numbers should be the same right and
then you go okay
so it looks like this and then you
factorize what is this this is um -
foreign - isn't it okay so what's broken
down okay in fact in some ways this is
easier to identify than this because
from your first line that was my point
but from my first line there be sneaky
you see the restrictions are there the
restrictions are there just like the
restrictions are here right excuse me
from the left-hand side
yeah right just have a look at that
original question what's the restriction
if that's all you saw what was tricking
would you say X's got a big greater than
or equal to negative 1 right ah but then
when you add in the other side okay
because the square root the left-hand
side has two positive right well that
means the right-hand side also has to be
positive or zero okay now which of those
is a more important more dominant sort
of restriction the answer is it's
actually this one isn't it this one's
more restrictive than this one right
because it's kind of like look here's
these negative one to the right okay but
zero
see the right blocks off these solutions
in here okay so this is actually the one
you want to think about which is why
even though this answer
I think should satisfy this it does not
satisfy this heads it breaks okay so now
you have a look at this and you've got
again two restrictions right what's
their stricken here from them you've got
2x Plus 8 right that's got to be what
restriction do we have on it that's got
to be greater than zero right so of
course I guess you would take that
across you would divide through and so
on you get a rejection for X in exactly
the same way you've got a restriction on
X there right this is the one takes over
okay so that's why you're negative two
gets knocked out it's a really easy
mistake to make
okay and it's a two-unit thing so watch
out